la journée de liam n'est pas ce qu'elle
devait être mais dès que je suis d'avis
que l'erreur d'un mois fait remarquer
que vous n'y avait pas d'école c'est de
sa mère non plus par une autre de covile
je dis non non là c'est la grève mon
vieux tu peux retourner de coucher les
comprends parce que l'école je sais que
ça paye pour beaucoup pas de travail
pour le moment pas de fête costumée pour
les enfants c'était pas un maire dit
journée parce qu'être mignotte du truc
spécial régime dans ce petit d'alwyn ya
l'école
des 1000 travailleurs de l'été en beauté
ces dernières semaines en faveur d'un
mandat de grève
cinq minutes entre eux des agents
correctionnels de chauffeurs d'autobus
des employés des traversées de
l'éducation notamment l'ont mis à
exécution lundi cinq mille autres
pourraient s'ajouter un choix
aujourd'hui de commencer ce groupe un
choix d'impacter le système d'éducation
est un choix d'un pâté système de santé
au coeur du litige les augmentations de
salaires 35 millions de dollars c'est
par des partis sur un budget provincial
de 10 milliards de dollars blige a
promis de redresser les finances de la
province l'une des plus pauvres du pays
comme elle était
j'ai pas envie que ça soit fermé de
trois semaines mauvaise nouvelle pour
sarrail les parents de cent mille jeunes
néo-brunswickois toutes les écoles nord
sud est ouest france angle
passé à l'apprentissage de domicile
lundi et ça va continuer jusqu'à la fin
d'une grève le gouvernement fermer
écoles et pourrait recourir à l'adoption
d'une loi spéciale pour les travailleurs
non essentiels de la santé par exemple
rousseau dommage de ne pas être allé
travailler parce que j'ai avec les
fermetures covin tout cela la difficulté
à prendre un rythme
même si les aime la trottinette ses
enfants veulent aller à l'école en
personne ben je lui dis retourne à la
table puis vite parce que nous autres on
a besoin que les écoles soient ouvertes
nos enfants ils ont besoin de ça ça va
faire le niaisage donnez-leur leur
contrôle puis
je choisis mes mots gentiment pour le
moment aucune rencontre n'est prévue
entre les parties et simo montambault
radio-canada bon buteur